il vous était déjà possible de parcourir
l'île de france au travers de ces cités
personnages historiques l'application
paris-région aventure se tournent
désormais vers les jo de 2024 de
n'importe où dans les yvelines et même
dans le monde vous pouvez vous frotter à
ce jeu de piste géant et découvrir les
athlètes emblématiques de leur
discipline ainsi que les étoiles
montantes c'est permettre en fait je que
les enfants puissent connaître ce qu'est
la magie des jeux c'est finalement les
préparer à la magie des jeux c'est parce
que c'est finalement qui qui ensuite
deviendront les ambassadeurs de notre
région aussi bien auprès de leurs
propres familles quand ils deviendront
grands et auprès également de leurs amis
qui pourront venir d'autres pays allez
on va s'y essayer une fois que vous avez
lancé l'application le jeu vous donne le
choix entre deux personnages un
personnage masculin un personnage
féminin tom ou emma on va choisir tom
pour cette aventure une fois le jeu
charge et vous accédez à une carte
interactive
les sites qui vont nous intéresser se
trouve à l'ouest de l'ile-de-france sur
la partie gauche de votre écran va donc
zoomer sur ces sites et cliquez sur
l'une des flamme olympique
et la rédaction de tv 78 on ne va pas
aller très loin puisqu'on va se rendre
tout de suite au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines sur la carte
qui est l'un des sites hôte des épreuves
de paris 2024 à chaque fois votre
personnage apparaît sur la carte vous
avez un petit joystick virtuel sur le
côté bas de votre écran qui vous permet
de vous déplacer vous le voyez
dans votre espace
il suffit d'aller voir le maître du jeu
le maître du jeu va vous lancer un défi
à chaque fois trouvé trois objets en
rapport direct avec le site olympique en
question et là il s'agit de trouver un
vélo un casque et des lunettes c'est
parti
leur ouvre des clés du stade ou du lieu
et une fois à l'intérieur il ya un mix
entre des images immersif qui leur
demande de chercher aussi des objets on
leur demande de scanner certains
éléments de répondre à des quizz ce qui
permet de répondre à un certain nombre
de défis pour découvrir du coup les
athlètes et les collectionner et quels
athlètes se cache derrière cet indice il
s'agissait d'axel etienne athlètes de
bmx bien sûr et une petite description
vous aident à découvrir cet athlète axel
etienne qui a déjà un palmarès fourni
mais qui est encore très jeune 23 ans et
qui sera l'une des pépites à suivre bien
sûr pour paris 2024 à chaque fois que la
khl a été trouvé une petite question
vous est posée ensuite je vais pas y
répondre parce que ce serait vous donner
toutes les clés pour réussir ce jeu il
faut que vous puissiez découvrir par
vous même et bien sûr vous pouvez
découvrir l'ensemble des autres sites
saint quentinois le golf national situé
à guyancourt la colline d'elancourt qui
va accueillir les épreuves de vtt du
côté de la commune d'hallencourt
forcément mais aussi la ville de
versailles qui va accueillir plusieurs
épreuves en tout en ile de france se
sont dit cette aventure qui vous emmène
à la découverte de paris 2024 on a les
sites de paris intra muros on a le stade
de france on a le parc des princes on a
la base aquatique de vaires sur marne
on a évidemment grand nombre des
principaux sites de compétition de paris
2024 l'application est gratuite elle est
disponible sur l'appstore et sur google
plaît c'est à votre tour
[Musique]